what if reading I don't know what photos
that I did I did I don't eat sweets I'm
here in Sintra Portugal at the
invitation of the European Central Bank
and they've invited me to come here to
make a video about economics which is a
subject that I know absolutely nothing
about but fortunately there are some
people here who I've been able to ask
for some help with at least the basics
it's a great question what is economics
it's a very difficult question okay you
know I think the first thing to bear in
mind is there isn't one answer and
economics is appealing because it's sort
of in some broad sense it's the study of
how humans make decisions we the
definition is something to do with the
management of limited resources why do I
get the impression I'm in over my head
here
we're here in central because there's a
conference happening about central
banking and so there are a bunch of
incredibly important economists here
like people who head up at Central
Bank's from all over the world but I'm
not here to talk to them I've been
brought here by the ECB to talk to some
PhD students who are here presenting
their research to these economists so I
was brought here to have a chat with
them about their theses my name is Colin
Chino and my research is in subsidies in
the housing market in so my name is
Jonathan sometimes I go by Joe I'm
interested in weight setting my name is
Rome foo
so my PhD focuses on financial economics
and macro economics I am the definition
maybe say my name is Michelle I'm a PhD
student at the University of Oxford and
my research is in macroeconomics supply
chains in monetary policy now if you're
anything like me before I came here you
might think of economics is something
that is practiced by banks rather than
something that is researched like a
science there is the question is
economics of science which I asked the
PhD students and these were their
responses the obvious answer is what is
the science you know that's not like and
not a helpful answer macroeconomics is
the macro economy isn't probably
yes they said enough of an answer no so
to give you some background on what a
PhD in economics is like what you
research I wanted to give these students
a platform on my channel just to very
briefly in this video talk about what
their PhDs are about so let's take let's
take the beginning of the sort of a
financial crisis the Great Recession in
the US UK Europe suddenly unemployment
goes from you know 5% to 10% and in a
few months maybe a year why does that
happen I thought this would be something
that macro economists understood really
well but one of the exciting things
about the research I do is that we don't
yet fully understand my first chapter is
about stalkery term prediction using
flexible models so that one is kind of
like econometrics
so I study the mortgage interest
deductibility which is a subsidy on
mortgages and borrowing and I study what
happens when that one the subsidy is
removed on for example what happens with
house prices what what happens with the
level of debt in the economy and
ultimately our households better or
worse off if the subsidies removed my
second paper which I'm going to present
here is my financial aid equation in the
changing world is about like measuring
financial integration and how to predict
us and whether it increases or not over
time the basic question I'm trying to
answer is the following standard models
assume that if you want to produce a car
you just bring people in the producer
call I would like this assumption I see
if you need to produce a car to produce
tires and she produced a metal from
which the car is made you need to
produce the glass for the for the car as
well and I'm trying to incorporate this
features into macroeconomic models and I
show that incorporating that is very
very important for understanding
monetary policy I think my research
matters a lot for for the average
households like purchasing a house is
one of the probably the biggest
financial decision or investment you
make in your life so how this mortgage
market is set up how how much debt you
can use to finance your mortgage or if
to finance your house purchase
if it's important for for most people
the question you want to answer is why
does unemployment arise so far and so
far this recession stopped them and if
we want to stop this this sort of this
phenomenon with enormous social
consequences we need to understand why
it happens and what I'm doing when I'm
looking at sort of large online datasets
job postings with wages is helping thing
to reach the root cause of why
unemployment rises so much which is
something that we don't yet fully
understand even in 2018
so there's your background all these
guys are studying very different
projects and so they're gonna have very
different responses to the big question
the reason you're watching this video
how is the world gonna change what is
coming it's gonna change the world
economy oh that's such an easy question
if I ever knew that would be great
the media narrative is that artificial
intelligence is super important but it
in practice we haven't yet measured it
carefully enough to know for sure and
this is something M great let me say two
things if you started with
cryptocurrencies I think it's also a big
thing why because we are moving from
cryptocurrencies as Bitcoin or some
other similar cryptocurrencies to this
whole conversation about script the
currency issued by a central bank you
know ten years ago an investment
professional would be extremely valuable
but today they might not be because you
could train an algorithm to do many of
the same chances this narrative is
popular but it's quite hard to test it's
one of the things I'm doing is trying to
get data that can let us test this the
second big topic is fiscal policy why
because you know that economists often
talk about the monetary policy as being
in the science of our you know over our
discipline the risk of possibly alchemy
there's still very limited understanding
of how exactly action by you know the
government either spending on goods and
services or the government doing some
taxation how exactly what is the optimal
way of doing that I think we shouldn't
worry too much about this because just
like 100
ago when we was really in touch with
life reform like also we also have
machines like replacing like all the
houses and technology is kind of like
the key for economic growth I'll be
honest I feel like I left this
conference with more questions than
answers like if yours like very very
little is certain in economics if
anything as the result of this trip I
now think of economics more and more
like climate science like there's this
vastly complicated system that you're
trying to model you have different
models for it and depending on the
assumptions that go into those models
you get really different outcomes they
really quite similar fields but not just
that
talking to the phd's has really made it
clear to me that we're more alike than
we are different we all have a lot in
common
I mean it's been tough a lot of work but
it's also been fun and it's I mean it's
an amazing freedom to be able to do
whatever you want to study exactly what
you're interested in
it's really hard to be originated all
right
especially just as a PhD student as a
start and it's kind of like impossible
for you to come up with like a totally
totally new idea and you think you would
change the whole world with this idea
that's because you hadn't really enough
literature well whenever they tell you
okay the next time we'll check up on
using about 18 months time you suddenly
get a lot of temptation to start doing
very casual you know recreational
thinking pondering about macroeconomics
instead of producing results of course I
hope that my PhD in social utility but I
do it in some level most of all because
I love doing and so I don't have to
justify to anyone because we who say why
are you doing it I'd say do it because
it's my passion and it might experience
be think to do and really get a lot out
of a PhD you need to you need to want to
do it for the pure joy of it
irrespective of how much it might
improve the world because that's a very
hard thing to do and you know it's a
very lofty and perhaps unattainable goal
for research see it's not just me thanks
to the ECB for inviting me to come
make this video I would encourage you to
follow them on Twitter and to check out
their website because before I came here
I didn't know anything about ECB what it
was or what it did and is this really
important institution for Europe and I
think it's worth learning about so go to
those links they'll be in the
description but also come back next week
because I'm gonna be posting a vlog
about my time here in sintra and all the
landscapes you seen behind an amazing
Palace down there this has been the
venue for the conference and I'm gonna
be doing this blog about my couple of
days here but meeting the students about
making this video and hopefully more
than that getting answers to questions
that you posted on social media about
economics I'm gonna do my very best
tomorrow to get answers to those so make
sure you subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss that if you enjoyed this
video make sure you give it a like and
thank you very much for watching I hope
you've learned something like I have in
the process of making it thank you for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one